Thanks yeah so if you are having trouble
with your wife I imagine how I felt
about an hour ago and i found out that
revealed j/s and jupiter notebook slides
require Wi-Fi to download the CSS and
JavaScript that makes them work I was
kind of panicking but they work at its
able to download the files get it
running locally so pro tip if you're
going to use reveal be aware of that
alright so yeah I'm this is a bit loud
what we see playing in turn the sound a
little bit excuse me so I'm going to
talk about um try to put as many buzz
words in my title as I possibly good i'm
going to talk about basically combining
three open source technologies which to
be clear i had basically nothing to do
with two implements a machine learning
workflow and the three things i'm going
to climb here are custom machine
learning for that I'm going to use
tensorflow and I'm going to use a
standard interface for machine learning
so that I can you know what it come up
with what the tensile model that I have
I can use in existing you know existing
workflows that we have and compare and
easily swap in with other machine
learning algorithms and then finally a
simple distributed computing library
called job lib which is actually
integrated as I could learn but it
provides some functionality to let you
implement a custom back ends so that you
can distribute processing according to
however your stack is set up okay so
yeah yeah and so I realized last night
that I have a little bit too much
content here so I'm going to go through
pretty quickly so first custom machine
learning I'm so it's been really amazing
how much easier she and learning
implementation has gotten over the past
few years it's getting almost to the
point where it's like just writing
equations on the whiteboard and then you
have sort of this very scalable reliable
fast implementation um I'll talk a
little bit about tensorflow and Theano
and things like that and why they are
useful
to start with kind of gives a background
gives me motivation to be clear the
focus in this talk is supervised
discriminative machine learning with
gradient based optimization this is used
for deep learning also sort of just um
logistic regression or linear regression
retrogression things like that would
also fall into this category there are
of course other types of machine
learning their tree ensembles or
probabilistic graphical models there are
also some very interesting tools sort of
analogous to tensorflow for graphical
models things like high mt3 and Stan if
you're not aware of those I would
recommend checking them out but attend
suppose sort of provides facilities to
implement supervised discrimination
learning models among other things so
with discrimination machine learning
we're trying to find a function so this
is a little bit maybe elementary but
it's kind of want to get everybody on
the same page when I'm talking about
since the flow so we want to find a
function that will output some why some
label or some target value given some
features X and some parameters W and
finding those right parameters for a
model is is the goal and the machine
learning algorithm so for example the
features could be counts of words in a
movie review and then maybe the the
output labels would be for the targets
would be positive negative sentiment
whether it was like a good review or
better view so typically waited to solve
this problem is to find a good function
prediction function is to use video
based optimization this is a text and
technique with deep learning and neural
networks and so it's sort of consists of
at a high level three steps first we
define our objective function called G
here that takes some training data x and
y and then also we want to so I feel
like this is a little bit too loud still
further our goal is to find a setting
for the weights W that sort of optimizes
Jean so this would be like or so it
could be like minimizing some loss
function or
amazing some some probability or score
and often this is G is defined as sort
of a difference between the predictions
that the prediction function currently
gives and the true targets that we that
we have on our training day so the
second second step is to then take that
function and then for the machine
learning algorithm we need to take steps
towards finding be the optimum and so
for that I will typically find a
derivative of G with respect to W so we
know which direction to take our steps
and so this this is actually really
really painful without something like
tensorflow because you basically have to
implement your objective function and
then you also have to implement your
gradient and there's basically sort of
separate things and and also sometimes
the gradient can be much more
complicated and then once you've done
your gradient you iterate you compute
the derivative of you update w you
iteratively do that until you reach
convergence or so you get tired of doing
it or he'll def validation go to
indicates that you should stop so tends
to flow and more generally graph based
in numerical computation methods like it
including fiano sort of really help this
process because for step one sort of
implementation of the objective function
that becomes much easier because it's
sort of a standard interface and tools
for a lot of the different functions you
want to do like soft max or a sigmoid
function all the matrix multiplication
things become much easier step 2 becomes
actually which was very hard before it
becomes one line of code literally you
say tensorflow down gradients and then
you know the inputs and output and what
he wants to gradient with respect to you
and then in step 3 because also becomes
maybe one or a few lines of code because
attentive phone and other tools like it
have learning algorithm these gradient
based learning algorithms already built
in so sorry I'm sort of them
proselytizing tensor plug in a little
bit but so yeah tense well it's it's
felt like Google's open source project
or
popular has kind of weirdly has more
stars than scikit-learn I think on
github but as I mentioned this
alternative tools particularly theano
there's a keris which is a nice rat very
nice very nice wrapper for both
tensorflow and Fiona and then a bunch of
other things there's they get released
like all the time I feel like God so
probably there's some have been released
since i started to some so if you went
yesterday to joel dual stock you about
fizzbuzz intensive oh you you've
probably already got a little bit of
this but i'm going to go through it
again well quickly so sort of brief
brief introduction of what tense fluids
and the different concepts for concepts
here so there's variables operations
graphs and sessions so what you do
intensive load to define your your
prediction function or your objective
function you're constructing a graph
where you have inputs and then you're
you're multiplying things together and
you're you have your weights and your
variables that you want optimized and
then finally at the top you you would
have your objective function so you're
defining this graph so first you
instantiate one of those and then as
sort of a convenience thing instead of
having to do like graph dad every time
you want to add something to your graph
sensible has this nice sort of context
management there's also a default graph
but unless you want to have global
variable it's probably terrible to use
the context manager and then you define
placeholders which would be inputs so
this would be like for example features
that model would make predictions about
oh yeah and this example here is just a
really stupid simple example where it's
just that there's a variable that's a
sum of things and that's just adding
things into that so we have the
placeholders what we're going to add
will have some variable which will store
a state in machine learning this would
actually be like a weight in a parameter
for a variable and then we have to have
an operation to initialize the variables
here you said that we want to initialize
with zero it also initialized randomly
for
neural network for example and then
we'll have another operation to do
things will add operations for actually
doing the work that we want in this case
we're just going to add the sum add add
the input to the sum and then sign it to
the sum so we're just incrementing sort
of here by the input then there's also a
session and so there's this a little bit
maybe not the most intuitive thing in
the world but sessions I I sort of think
of it it's rough analogy but I think
about graph as sort of like an
executable in UNIX and then a session is
a little bit like a process where it has
it has the state so it's maintaining
state for these these variables so the
graphs have sort of just described how
the the processing works but then when
it's actually running this session sort
of manages that so and then you can run
multiple commands within a session so
you can check the initial value and then
you can add things to it add a few
different vectors of input and you see
you know you'll get the outputs another
point is if you make another session
then you've lost all those all those
values and you start back at the initial
value by the way I'm going to tweet
these slides later so people can take a
look in more detail so as I mentioned
before tense flow provides this
automatic differentiation magic which is
amazing so basically every node and that
graph it knows how to differentiate it
and then it can just propagate down the
graph but so you know if you define a
simple function then you can take the
gradient of it to make sure i'm actually
highlighting singsong screen if you take
the gradient of it that's just one line
then you have your gradient and then you
can that and run it and get your
creative things right so that's very
easy so ok that's the tensile
introduction next I'm going to talk a
little bit about multi-layer perceptrons
which is the sort of framework coming to
move forward with the rest of the talk
so this is a very very sort of simple
basic sort of thick thick or sort of
first neural network people think about
uh it's a feed-forward neural network
there that means there's no recursion in
its and also there's no convolutions as
you would see in an image processing
Network so basically what we have is an
input layer and one or more hidden
layers and then an output layer and the
nice thing is unlike a linear model
where you just have basically an input
layer and an output layer you can model
interactions between features so complex
relationships in fact if you have one
layer I believe that just thing called
the universal approximation theorem that
says you can approximate any function as
long as that layers wide enough so multi
other sub friends are not not something
new then had something fancy it's
actually quite an old idea but there are
is the nice thing is it sort of combines
with all the state-of-the-art neural
network methods so you can use rel you
activation functions and drop out which
is kind of like regularization and all
the way to sort of created based
optimization techniques yeah that's not
good I hit diagram um and now the
battery so here we go so I had a diagram
I don't know when I blame Wi-Fi um
although its local so it's my fault um
there's an input layer I had diagram at
the input layer and hidden layer a
player but basically a multi-layer
perceptron is like this you're trying to
make some prediction of a target y and
yeah I'm just going to skip the slide
actually um but then at the interesting
the thing I wanted to point out here is
there's this the first few layers are
going to be seeing a shame for a lot of
different models so if you're doing
classification first few layers that the
same as if you're doing regression with
multi-layer perceptron the only
difference there would be the output
function and and and you're sorry yeah
the output layer and the objective
function that you're going to maximize
or minimize
um right so I'll talk a bit about how I
implemented this but first I'm going to
go on and talk about so I could learn a
little bit so okay this flow gives you
the ability to implement custom machine
learning models but it's you know might
not fit in it doesn't immediately fit
into sort of a psychic learn framework
that we serve all know and love so and
this sort of doesn't you can sort of do
whatever you want you know define your
your own API but it's kind of nice to
have a sort of a standard API to work
with so that it can sort of you could
swap in the multi-layer perceptron and
swap in a gradient boosting or swap in
logistic regression try a whole bunch of
all the all the different things that
scikit-learn provides and so we wanted
to I wanted to implement this following
this standard scikit-learn API this is
of course as I said not met built by me
but is a very very nice consistent API
that makes swapping and different
between learning our than to trying
different things very easy they all
follow a very standard interface there's
there's helper functions which help you
with your things like input validation
pre-processing testing there's also
talked yesterday by Tom about
implementing a transformer it's very
similar but here I'm going to be
implementing a predictor particular
class firing regressors here and another
very important part of this is that it
has there's some very nice functionality
to actually check that what you're
implementing follows the actual API so
they have a whole suite of tests unit
tests will run on your custom estimator
to make sure that it actually is a
custom scikit-learn estimator not just
some piece of code um yeah another thing
that cycle learn makes easy is its grid
search over hyper parameters which I'll
talk a little bit outs but to implement
a psychic learn predictive model what we
need to do is in
lament fit and predict methods those are
the two key things also it's
probabilistic model if you can give you
probabilities as predictions and input
predict prabha the unit function just
needs to attach arguments it's a little
strange and actually like your your
editors made complaint because you know
python you're really supposed to that's
the title that define all the member
variables in unit functionally but a lot
of the work that an it does actually is
done in the fit method once once you
have the training data that that you're
going to do that you're going to use to
train Moloch and then fit also usually
attaches some some interest instance
attributes such as for logistic
regression you get data coefficient
matrix everything should be serializable
with pickle and then there's also some
nice mix ins with this that will use
okay so yeah I implemented a multi lip
subjoin using pencil flow and set it up
to follow the second learning API has
some nice features you know we get GPU
support for free through tensorflow uses
can take in such sparse or dense matrix
matrices which is slightly interview
with tensorflow yet there's a generic
base class as I mentioned the first few
layers are are the same regardless of
whether you're doing regression or
classification so you know a lot of that
code doesn't have can be reuse and cuz
I'm really bad at naming I called a
multi-layer feed forward neural network
called it muffin it's it's on big github
I'm not trying to clean with this is the
best thing in the world there are
alternative approaches you could take in
particular scikit-learn has an MLP
classifier uses a cpu there's a
tensorflow learn a contributor of poor
learning support but maybe not as good
of matching the psychic learning api and
then there's also curious which is very
nice which provides some functionality
to wrap models
our deep learning models in something
that looks like psycho learning yet but
let me let me talk a little bit about
this go through this real quick um so
what this looks like so this is this is
the base class that sort of implements
first two two thin layers and Fred's
abstract methods for providing for
implementing the output layer and the
objective function H 1 optimized in your
model so as I said it imports some so I
could learn um imports the face
estimator from scikit-learn sorry
extends that subclass of it and then the
main thing is the fit method and as I
noted before my introduction to blow we
need to define a graph that we're going
to add all the operations soo in the
variables our weights are inputs all the
layers of the network I'll have this on
the next slide but we're going to
initialize a model here and then we'll
also have a session so when we're
training the model we will store that
the values of our weights and law in the
network and then we'll do learning down
here we'll go through a number of
iterations through the training data and
well part of the Predators will have a
learning algorithm that will yet will be
will be will be running updates down
here where we pass in the mini batches
of the training examples so there's some
abstract methods we need to implement
and but the the core modeling code looks
like this so this is the actual tensile
a part of of implementing multi-layer
perceptron so there's there's so dropout
is this sort of it's like regularization
sort of probability of dropping inputs
and network as we're training and so we
have a value for a placeholder to be
able to turn that off because you
actually want to turn that off when
you're making predictions so we have
placeholder for that as an input and
then we also have the input layer here
and then the class takes a hidden units
keyword argument which defines the how
many layers in your network there are
and how
large each of those layers layers is so
it takes a list of integers so if you
had a 256 256 256 you have three layers
with 256 units each so will iterate over
those values and add layers for each one
of them and then we'll initialize our
objective function which depends on the
particular or sorry initialize our
output in our objective function depends
on the particular others classification
regression and then we'll define our
learning algorithm and as I mentioned
the tensorflow has some nice sort of all
the latest learning algorithms our
muscle latest learning algorithms
implemented already you can very easily
set up your training yet so one problem
is tensile it doesn't pickle very well
so this maybe there's better way around
this but had sort of implement what I
would like to call a hack so tends to
flow has a saber class but as far as I
can tell it can only write to disk but
thankfully you can override get state
method in Python objects that that
pickle uses when it's trying to save
something so I initially end up doing is
writing a model to disk reading in his
fights and then pickling those bites I'm
doing that when you want to load it back
in so some kind of crazy i'm just going
to skip over that code eh to the time
not that difficult so here's what the
subclass looks sorry here's what the
classifier subclass looks like as I said
we need to implement our model output
and here it's going to depend on on
whether we're doing multi-label
classification multi-class
classification or binary classification
I could have actually implemented these
as three different subclasses but I
chose to sort of follow its I could
learn already had four random forests
where they limit these three things in
the classifier so we we have a you know
different a little bit of control flow
sentence here to decide you know what
what type of model we're doing but then
at the end we define our output layer
and they also have a function to
initialize our objective function to
define what that should be for our model
and here for a binary classification
would be a sigmoid cross entropy between
the the predictions and the ed and push
our soy de target labels in our training
data and as and yeah it's important to
know that you know times of flow
provides this for you you don't have to
find it for yourself because it's very
standard method for deep learning and
then there's a little bit of logic and
predicts and predict Bravo those very
pretty easy to implement so third part
of the talk um simple distributed
computing so an issue with what deep
learning is all these layers all these
neurons lots of matrices and tensors
whatever flowing around it can get kind
of slow so and also there's always hyper
parameters like whether using dropout
with a drop it should value should be
how many layers using what size of those
layers very large space it's very
similar to like gradient boosting we
have all these parameters related to how
many the depth of the trees and things
like that and so you sort of want to
explore the space and try a lot of them
on your training data with cross
validation before you you sort of pick
what this proper setting should be and
train train the whole train final model
so yeah the typical source Xander way to
do this is good search with cable cross
validation on the training data this is
sort of a crude method it's basically
you know root forcing the solution
trying much points on a grid but the
nice thing is it's embarrassingly
parallel because one grid point doesn't
depend on you know the model training
one grid point doesn't end model
training the other good point so we can
very very easily paralyzed this where we
just run all the good points apparel and
then at the end find out which you know
which one is best there's alternative
Piper primitive search methods they're
also parallelizable to some extent it's
worth mentioning yeah so I just ran on a
second learn digits data set which is
regression just to show you that this is
actually important but this probably
pretty well known here but like you know
the default value would be this and then
you
you know about ten percent better if you
do some tuning and with deep learning
this would be more pronounced so you get
a totally useless model if you picked
around perimeters or really good I'm so
for this will use job lib this is a
Python package for running these sorts
of embarrassing Lee parallel tasks again
not spelled on me it's originally I
believe focus just on single machine
parallelization because they're back
ends for multi-processing
multi-threading um so here's a simple
actually I'm just going to skip this for
in the interest of time but the sort of
it's very easy to use so you can define
a function that you can paralyze it and
that'll run on in this little bit of
code run on in multiple processes and
computing to these numbers separately
that's a separate process um so a key
thing is scikit-learn actually uses job
lib in the grid sir cv so if you set the
number of jobs perimeter other than just
defaults to one you said it's a 10 it
will use 10 processes and also if you
tell job lib before calling before doing
the grid search if you tell job lip to
use a custom back-end that you've
implemented then scikit-learn with will
use that custom back-end that custom job
live backend for grid search and to show
you what that looks like later but um
yeah so as I mentioned job live sort of
originally just multi-processing
multi-threading I believe but now it has
support for custom parallel backends has
a nice API for that so an example this
has a desk distribute it back in and
make you want for spark or something
enough but to implement one of these you
have to implement two things you have to
implement class representing a pending
result so something representing
something a task running on a separate
machine or separate process except to
thread this is basically a very similar
to current future there's a get method
which will retrieve of which will block
wait for the results and then there's a
result there's a result attribute will
just cash the result
um and then you have to implement the
back end base subclass so you have to
subclass this parallel back-end base
notice actually in a private method but
there's an issue to make that public
because there's no reason why it should
be public um basically all you have to
do here is implement it apply async
method which will cute which will take a
function that you want to run and cue it
up for compensate that it started and
then return one of these pending results
instances so soon as we have our own
custom our own auto scaling ec2 amazon
ec2 docker based system for running jobs
in the cloud they're there all the other
systems you know Cabernets invasives
things like that I probably do this sort
of thing with but for the purposes talk
i'm just going to talk about our well
i'm going to just use our infrastructure
not really go and talk too much about it
but so we wanted to implement the job
lip custom backend for for our
infrastructure we actually already had a
concurrent futures executors sub class
or interface to our system which allow
us to sort of easily submit commands to
and run things on docker containers and
we use job live to make this easier to
work with slack line um so I think in
the interest of time I will skip this as
well but sort of an outline of our Moses
kivett and outline of our of our
back-end and so as I said we have to
implement the async method and then also
this result okay so I just want to wrap
up with sort of a little basic
evaluation just to show you not not
whether it's the best thing world but
you know doesn't work okay so first I'm
just going to prepare a multi-layer
perceptron to just let just aggression
for a text classification task look at
model accuracy there and then the second
step is all compare researching on my
laptop to good searching in
they're cloud in terms of just how long
it takes okay so set up with the
evaluation for text classification
that's a nice movie reviews data sets
from an ACL paper several years ago has
a couple as movie reviews with positive
negative sentiment labels fun date set
and the features here for our models are
going to be just character and grams is
it just going to come from psychic
learns count vectorize or method and
this is actually a pretty good NLP my
background soliciting NLP but this this
is actually a pretty pretty strong
bassline I think our evaluation set
setup is a little bit different from the
original paper but we're going to
randomly split the reviews into training
and testing sets and then we're going to
do a hyper parameter grid search on the
training set and then we're going to
evaluate the the final model that we get
out of the grid search using a HD score
for testing set predictions it will
import some stuff so NLC k the package
channel TK provides the new reviews sort
of pre parse and ready to go very easy
to set up set up the data set that way
so here's how we're going to implement
the experiments very very simple once we
have all these things put together we
have our count vector Iser which will
take text which will transfer tape texts
input and output let's see matrices with
indicator indicators for particular
character in grams will be very sparse
matrix and here we'll it will actually
extract all the ink grams sorry Ingram
would be subsequence of well in this
case for character and gram subs you and
subsequence of continuous character than
the input so you know little letter
Frank word fragments and spaces between
words and things like that so we'll go
from two characters in row all the way
to five characters or else we'll extract
all those features very very sort of
simple knowledge free great no
linguistic knowledge here um then we
will instantiate our multi
perceptron classifier will throw that
into a psychic learn pipeline and in
order to grid search will define a
parameter grid here we'll do a very very
simple perimeter grid just an explorer a
network with 500 with a one hidden layer
of 512 units and another network with
one hidden layer of 256 units and then
another network which would be a little
bit deeper where we have three hidden
layers in practice you would probably
want to try lots more of different
configurations of hidden layers and then
also we either turn drop out on or off
sort of the basic point five level it
and then we'll throw that into a grid
search CB and I said it here I set it to
use for jobs because there's two cores
and hyper floating in my laptop because
reason and then the ledge discretion is
basically the same thing sorry the
microphone just keeps kind of dying here
I'm not sure what um will instantiate
the logistic regression class from so I
can learn instead and then our parameter
grid will be slightly different we'll
just tune over the el tube penalty so
then we'll fit those to do our grid
search on the training set and I'll turn
away for a little while and not
surprisingly the image discretion is
much faster it takes about four minutes
the multiset Ron takes almost an hour in
terms of accuracy the multiple
perceptron does a little bit better a
couple points I don't really know
whether this is a you know meaningful
but uh it's nice to see it shows it
works um and then then we'll do this
with our distribute it back in and this
becomes very easy I implemented a class
to sort of instantiate one of these back
end objects and then we'll register it
will call the civis back end and then to
actually run the grid search on that
back ends we will use a context manager
that job lip provides and then any
happening with job live within this
context we'll use our custom back end so
when scikit-learn does when cyclone
skirt suits EV wants to fit in and score
model it will do that using our are
distributed easy two base in our
infrastructure and it's faster um it's
not like magically faster but it's quite
a bit faster from an hour to 15 minutes
a important thing here is it actually
once it's done doing the grid search
this also includes fitting the final
model that did best in the grid search
on on my laptop right so that's pretty
much it but some parting thoughts these
are kind of speculation don't have a ton
of evidence to back up these assertions
but with deep learning Hyperborea
research and speeding up is really
really really really important it's kind
of a key to getting it to work and so
you know the fact that Google is doing
really well this is not surprising
because they have all the infrastructure
to do this a perimeter search and my
opinion is that for most people for most
applications doing that figuring out how
to do the very simple easily
parallelizable distributed grid search
is probably more important than than
figuring out more complicated sort of
process of how to distribute the actual
model fitting procedure which is another
thing that machine learning research
reserve act actively investigating so if
you have like really really giant like
click-through data or something we have
like trillions of instances trained on
it may be distributed model fitting
would be really really important but for
for most models created boosting on
medium sized aliens data set to keep
learning on medium sized data set be
distributing that grid search is going
to be really really helpful and then
find a point with combining these tools
it's you know we combine three things
but you know the be whole is greater
than the sum of its parts um thanks for
people to code review contributed to the
alright so we have five minutes
yeah yeah so there are there are
different methods where oh sorry here's
gonna forget that listening repeat the
question yeah so the question was
basically this brute force grid search
is really expensive and you know there's
got to be a better way um yeah so yeah I
think they're they're basically there
are methods this is really an active
learning area of research and there
there are methods even and I think
scikit-learn has a couple options to do
these things um I my impression right
now is that they like you know most of
the time to work but then sometimes they
won't and most of the time that work a
little bit better than grid search
probably but then sometimes you know
make sure they won't work at all or kind
of screw up so I don't tickle you trust
them i think maybe a couple more years
there'll be this this will be something
that people have figured out but I I
think it will still be computationally
expensive the sort of the space of
parameters so if you imagine sort of as
well multi dimensional function you know
you're trying to sort of optimize that
function and most machine learning
models like are at least locally convex
you know kind of smooth whereas this the
type of parameter space has all these
different things like really for great
boosting or something in a number of
trees you know how to split the trees
and splitting criteria and all these
different things learning rate and all
these things are very different and so
that space is is really not as smooth
and easy to to search around in and so
that's that's part of the reason why
people use grits are Butler people are
looking into a Bayesian methods to sort
of prior priors and cost this Mike Mike
really it's weird you know Bayesian
methods for doing that and then just
yeah there's there's hyper ops there's a
thing called hyper opt that people use
sometimes so that they're there I think
that this will be a really really active
than important learning area of research
but it will still require parallel
benefit from paralyzation I think
any other question I think this thing is
out of battery that's heilmann 13 I'm so
new to the yet reveal dance wow this
website there's any other questions
thank you